should have packed our snowshoes
what people do that you know fun fact
not only is it the oldest but remains
one of the most effective means of
traversing the ice
wow yeah you're gonna fit right in at
beaverfield
everything here is a little
questionable ranger the people
the weather everything
oh rachel
you look like you just seen a corpse
well the roads are
effed and something's wrong with the
generator which generator
all of them ain't get on the internet uh
also there's a dead body under your
[Applause]
porch
[Applause]
probably a wolf what are you like a wolf
detective no marcus
who knows who oh when
he's gonna kill next
i think we can all agree that it's
unsafe outside their safety in numbers
out of curiosity who is packing
well we're having a good old-fashioned
sleepover with guns though with guns yes
about this predator is unorthodox
it's not human it's not a canine
it's one of them one of what i like
a what a werewolf
look at it gotten in here
how did i get out
he says he got out
[Laughter]
maybe i'm a werewolf maybe you're a
werewolf
maybe you're a werewolf you're a
werewolf you're a whale
you're a werewolf
are we really in a mexican standoff
right now baby
don't say mexican just stand up
you know we're probably just gonna head
out just pull it
here we got it on our own it's just
hey you go ahead please don't spare me
oh please don't
oh please
please don't bother the luck oh yes i
could have gotten it
[Music]
you